welcome back to las vegas now as we
enter a new season it's time to get rid
of all that junk piling up in and
outside of your home right
right right oh yeah it's time all right
so who are you going to call the junk
luggers and eco-friendly junk and
furniture company ready to help you so
brad jimenez welcome to the show thank
you for having me so why is the service
so important specifically for las vegas
right so las vegas a lot of people don't
know uh because it's so far outside of
town we actually have the biggest
landfill in north america it's the apex
landfill right off highway 15 22 22 000
2200 acres my apologies pretty big
pretty big it's basically the size of
north lafayette north las vegas so it's
uh
try to keep items out of there as much
as we can yeah you're definitely doing a
great service for us so what what's the
process like when a customer calls what
happens right so a customer calls they
speak with one of our call center reps
uh we book their appointment we go out
we give uh estimates same day based on
the items uh they have available you
know anything we can handle any jobs big
or small um and we go out with a couple
of trained luggers they remove the items
same day and uh yeah that's that's
pretty much it that's pretty much it you
call you you do everything most of it
works after the fact so we uh we try to
work with part donation partners
donation centers here in town uh local
las vegas we work with faith lutheran we
work with hearts alive village castaways
a lot of charities we're really uh
passionate about here in town that's
awesome so it's about donating and
recycling not just throwing it in the
landfill yes ma'am yes ma'am we always
try to return our donation centers or
donation receipts to our customers like
to get those into their hands um yeah
anything we can do to just help the
community is kind of the idea that's
awesome brad okay and what are some of
the items that you see mostly anything
and everything a lot of furniture a lot
of people are getting rid of those couch
and love seat combos upgrading their
furniture a lot of beds we have actually
a recycler here in town who recycles
mattresses and box springs okay um so
pretty good yeah those don't wind up in
the landfills take up a lot of room
really yeah a lot of household items
like that and what about season wise do
you have like an influx of calls during
a certain time of the year how does that
work not particularly to be honest with
you summer's a little weird nobody wants
to move stuff outside in 120 degree heat
what about spring cleaning spring
cleaning's big spring cleaning's big
holidays are coming up everyone wants
their home to look good for the holidays
right that's we're expecting a pretty
big season coming up here pretty quick
exactly so how do people get in touch
with you guys give us a call at 1-800
lug junk l-u-g-j-u-n-k
or you can visit us online at junk
luggers of sw vegas.com simple as that
and one more time what are the charities
that you work with
hearts alive is a big one we love hearts
alive castaways is another big one and
uh faith lutheran are three main ones uh
we do work we're actually having a
e-waste recycling event coming up
awesome yeah united way we're gonna be
at their office on flamingo free e-waste
recycling event if you got anything with
a plug come by bring it down throw it in
the back of our truck we'll take it to
the recycling center and our proceeds
are going to united way that's a great
event you guys are helping the community
in more ways than one brad yes ma'am
thank you so much all right thank you to
junk luggers of southwest las vegas for
sponsoring this segment give them a call
at 1-800 lug junk or just visit junk
luggers of sw vegas